vor einigen wochen habe ich gut
aufgestellt die versprechen uns reich zu
machen aufbau eines dezentralen netzwerk
das die zukunft sein soll und
gleichermaßen kinderleicht einzurichten
ist meiner meinung nach eines der
vielversprechendsten club projekte
momentan weil es wirklich an berufen
aber wie geht es jetzt vier wochen nach
dem letzten video auf läuft mittlerweile
alles wo habe ich den zweiten router
aufgestellt und vor allem wie viel haben
wir verdient viel spaß mit der auflösung
von durch helium mining zurück
vorweg ist gab einige probleme aber erst
mal zurück zum anfang wir haben einen
wunderbaren spot für unseren ersten
meiner gefunden fünfzehnter stock über
50 meter hoch freie sicht von leverkusen
bis nach bonn also perfekte
voraussetzung für unsere männer das
problem er liebt einfach nicht und das
für geschlagene sieben tage sieben tage
in denen wir schon die ganze zeit hätten
geld verdienen können aber er lief
einfach nicht und genau dort ist das
erste video geändert also was war jetzt
das problem und wie konnte ich lösen
[Musik]
hatte ich nicht und wie durch zauberhand
hat genau dass alle probleme gelöst ich
weiß bis dato nicht was das problem war
aber es war irgendwann weg und der
meiner hat angefangen zu laufen und zwar
richtig
tag eins haben wir 0,54 helium gemein
tag 2 0,3 etwas schlechter nur um dann
an tag 3
1,09 helium an einem tag zu verdienen
das bedeutet dass wir in den ersten drei
tagen zum damaligen kurs von 40 euro
über 80 euro insgesamt in den ersten
drei tagen verdient haben was ein
absoluter traum ist und ich dachte ab
hier geht's genau nur so bergauf zum
damaligen kurs zum damaligen kurs denn
auch abseits der position gibt es
natürlich dinge die einfluss darauf
nehmen wie viel gewinnen wir im
endeffekt wichtig macht da wir in der
währung helium ausbezahlt werden hat der
kurs dieser währung natürlich einen
entscheidenden einfluss darauf wie viel
euro wie am ende wirklich rausholen
können und leider ging es vom 12.10.11
mit einem all time high von 740 euro
ziemlich geradewegs in eine richtung und
zwar nach unten naja aber erstmal zum
zweiten meiner den wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt ja noch gar nicht aufgestellt
hatten
gesagt getan am 25.11 habe ich dann
meine ersten konz verkauft mit circa 40
euro pro köln habe ich für 627 helium
genau 251 euro und 80 cent bekommen und
das alles nur aus gefühl weil ich dachte
es geht weiter bergab das ganze lief
erstmal so weiter meine 1 hat jeden tag
mit dem profit abgeworfen während meiner
2 in bochum lag und es wirklich keine
aussicht auf besserung gab dafür müsst
ihr verstehen dass es wirklich keinen
sinn hat den meiner an einer
suboptimalen position aufzustellen das
wäre wie auf einem markt auf dem nur
bananen angeboten werden einstand zu
eröffnen bei dem man schlechtere bananen
zum selben preis anbietet der profit
geht gegen null und genauso ist es bei
meiner auf und als wäre das noch nicht
genug hat mich am 5 12 folgende
nachricht von meinem helium mentor
erreicht der selber über 40 meiner schon
aufstellen konnte junge irgendein pizza
hat sich direkt neben sich gestellt und
trends mit geld ist auf 0,4 und das ist
so ziemlich worst case was einem als
helium einer passieren kann also ich bin
nicht der helium meiner sondern ich bin
da
um euch das wieder mit dem beispiel des
bananen markt zu erklären es wäre so wie
wenn jemand einen stand neben euch
aufmachen würde der genau dasselbe
produkt hat zu genau dem selben preis
der profit sinkt für beide die einzige
lösungen die wir dafür gesehen haben war
ihm eine nachricht bei hot spot zu
schreiben das ist ein portal dass viele
leute nutzen um ihre männer zu monitoren
und wir haben geschrieben hell bruder
guck mal passt mal auf wir waren zuerst
da dritte schiebt da in meiner
wenigstens in der app 20 meter von uns
weg und dann kann es schon sein es
besser wird aber es kam natürlich keine
reaktion das bedeutet werden erst mal
auf neue trends mit geld von 0,8 weiter
gemacht obwohl wir vorher fast ein
abriss mit scale hatten also das beste
vom besten was waren wirklich wilde tage
weil danach ging es direkt bergab also
es ging quasi die ganze zeit mit der
währung bergab ich bin eingestiegen
meiner hat angefangen zu arbeiten
während einem all time high das bedeutet
die währung war am höchstkurs jemals und
desto mehr meinen meiner angefangen hat
zu laufen desto weiter ging der kurs
unter weswegen ich mich am 17.12.10 dazu
entschieden habt noch mal zu verkaufen
alles was ich bis dato verdient und noch
nicht ausbezahlt hatte 4,23 helium für
29 euro und 61 cent was ein gewinn von
125 euro um 25 cent bedeutet hat das
bedeutet ab diesem zeitpunkt hatte ich
keinen einzigen medium kommen mehr auf
meinem konto aber dafür
376 euro und 15 was gut war und was sich
auch langfristig als schlaue
entscheidung herausstellen sollte die in
diesem zeitpunkt schon zu verkaufen denn
vielleicht ahnt jetzt schon das
schlamassel geht weiter zu dem zeitpunkt
war ich ziemlich verzweifelt meine 1
transmit geld komplett eingebrochen das
bedeutet auch unsere gewinne komplett
eingebrochen und meiner zwei absolut
unmöglich eine passende position zu
finden also habe ich überlegt was hat
denn jetzt gerade noch wert wie kann ich
weitermachen und bin auf die glorreiche
idee zu kommen mal zu schauen wie viel
so einen meiner gerade wert ist falls
ihr euch noch erinnert ich habe 1000
euro pro meiner ausgegeben das bedeutet
2000 euro insgesamt und als ich kleiner
zeigen geöffnet habe hat sich mir eine
ziemlich gute nachricht offenbar alle
meiner also bobcats stan skepsis der den
ich habe und noch viele andere alle dies
quasi gibt sind unglaublich krass im
preis gestiegen wie werden eigentlich im
retail für 350 454 euro verkauft und
werden mittlerweile für 1400 bis 1700
euro gehandelt das bedeutet alleine
dadurch dass ich den meiner zu hause
hatte und einfach nicht benutzt habe
habe ich 450 euro in einem monat
verdient also offensichtlich ich habe
keinen platz wo ich den hinstellen kann
der minor league trumm der ist im preis
gestiegen ich habe ihn natürlich bei
ebay kleinanzeigen eingestellt und
dadurch im endeffekt 450 euro profit nur
mit dem handel des meilers verdient
während der zweite beziehungsweise der
erste meiner ja immer noch weiter und
auch bei meiner 1 gab es langsam
erfreulicher nacht die person hat zwar
den männern nicht weggeräumt aber hatte
selber irgendwelche probleme mit ihrem
namen das bedeutet dass er einfach
offline war seit den letzten sieben
tagen es bedeutet gärten in den letzten
sieben tagen dann nochmal zeit mit einer
ordentlichen trends mit scale geld
rauszuholen aber irgendwann kam das
projekt zum ende und es kam der tag an
dem ich den meiner abbauen musste und
wir den kassensturz gemacht haben
all in all haben wir im letzten monat
mit einem meiner 12,55 helium gemeint
was ziemlich gut ist das kommt nämlich
bei einem euro betrag von
425 euro und 65 cent raus was richtig
richtig und ist hätte ich aber nicht
geschaltet und glück dabei gehabt dass
ich die zwischendrin schon zu den
besseren kurs verkauft hätte wäre es
deutlich weniger gewesen bei aktuellem
kurs wenn ich alles jetzt am letzten tag
verkauft hätte während es gerade einmal
3 134 euro und 45 cent gewesen das
bedeutet wir haben dadurch dass wir
zwischendrin verkauft haben über 100
euro mehr damit verdient aber ihr ahnt
es schon das war nicht der größte profit
dem wir in diesem projekt gemacht für
den ersten mal haben wir 450 euro über
einkaufspreis bekommt was 450 euro
gewinn bedeutet und beim zweiten haben
wir 470 euro über einkaufspreis bekommen
das ganze führt zu einem endbetrag von
1345 euro und 65 cent prof das ist
richtig ordentlich ich habe zwar nicht
damit gerechnet dass es im endeffekt die
männer sind die uns im profil bringen
aber wo das geld herkommt ist mir
ziemlich egal wir haben glück gehabt wir
waren früh auf der wave und wir konnten
ordentlich profit mitnehmen was das
einzige goal ist ihr merkt schon der
betrag der sich gallium aufbaut kommt
gefährlich nahe an den preis einer rolex
haben ich habe für januar ein riesen
finale forex trader geplant ich habe
schon einen partner gefunden der das
ganze mit mir umsetzen wird es wird ein
absolutes fest also vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren außerdem tut es mir
leid dass sie in diesem video nicht mehr
von draußen zeigen konnte ich hätte euch
gerne gezeigt wie ich noch nie in meiner
aufhänge wie ich spots usw aber das
ganze wurde im keim erstickt weil
einfach alles mittlerweile besetzt ist
es kommen täglich so unglaublich viele
meiner dazu dass es wirklich super
schwierig ist ein sport zu finden an dem
es sich wirklich noch lohnt also bevor
ihr euer geld zusammen mit unten in
helium einer kauft weil es ist cool es
macht spaß und ich kann das alles
verstehen schaut dass sie einen
vernünftigen sport habt und euch nicht
dasselbe passiert wie bei mir mit dem
zweiten meinung weil das bringt im
endeffekt gar nichts außer die preise
von meiner steigen aber das war jetzt
ein bisschen glück im unglück und trotz
alledem sind 1000 propheten knapp über
einem monat völlig absurd ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen wenn ja lass mir
gerne eine leica vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren und kein folgenden
videos und keine der informationen zu
verpassen die möglicherweise im nächsten
tagen und wochen hier auf diesem kanal
online kommen wir sehen uns nächste
woche donnerstag wieder bis dahin
[Musik]